You can imagine that if a text that we wanted
to analyze was really large, rather than a short book
like Alice in Wonderland, maybe a document containing all of
the books ever written. This script would take an extremely long
time. It might even be impossible to run the scripts,
due to the inability to fit all of that data onto
one machine. In this case, it makes sense to employ
MapReduce. How would I solve this problem using MapReduce? You can
imagine that if the text we wanted to analyze
was really large, rather than a short book like Alice
in Wonderland. Maybe a document containing all of the books
ever written, this script would take an extremely long time.
It might even be impossible to run the scripts due
to the inability to fit all of that data onto
one machine. In this case, it makes sense to employ
MapReduce. So how would I solve this problem using MapReduce?